on est bien peu de choses et mon ami la
rose me l'a dit ce matin
à l'aurore je suis née
je me suis épanouie
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre nouvel
épisode du petit ami la semaine dernière
rice musicien et ergothérapeute nous a
parlé de son travail sur la bande
originale du petit Emir cette semaine
nous partons à la découverte de Nicolas
l'un des percussionnistes du petit Emir
en compagnie de sa famille
comme chaque jour dès qu'il arrive chez
lui Nicolas va dire un petit bonjour à
son parrain qui est également son voisin
nous décidons ensuite d'interviewer les
parents de Nicolas et son parrain afin
qu'il nous parle de la vie de tous les
jours avec Nicolas alors quand Nicolas
est né c'est sûr qu'on ne s'attendait
pas à ce genre de d'événement difficile
à gérer mais on était très très entouré
donc au niveau professionnel au niveau
des amis et surtout au niveau de la
famille que ce soit les parents les
grands-parents
voilà donc on a on a fait front et on a
on a cherché des réponses qu'on n'a pas
toujours trouvé mais bon c'est pas grave
on s'est dit qu'il est là et on fera
tout pour qu'il grandisse comme un
enfant normal tu vois qu'il soit heureux
et ce qui était le plus important pour
nous
comme mon épouse c'est vrai qu'on
s'attendait on s'attendait pas d'avoir
un enfant handicapé on a dû
l'accompagner en métropole deux jours
après sa naissance et quand on a appris
le handicap un peu difficile au départ
et bien on s'est dit bon il est là il
faut qu'on l'entoure un maximum et du
coup maintenant on vit à trois c'est
comme le disait mon épouse c'est notre
boule d'amour on a on avance pas à pas
on essaie de l'entourer de le rendre
autonome maximum on à l'aide de toute la
famille on est Cédric il est bien
entouré et on se pose pas trop de
questions donc franchement il faut aller
pas à pas on a appris au fil du temps au
fur et à mesure la découverte et après
c'est vrai que
quand on essaie de faire le maximum quoi
moi en tout cas comme il aime bien
bricoler tout ben je la prends à faire
la débroussailleuse
assez avait un petit peu des des outils
comme il aime bien ça ben on s'est
adapté et puis ben on essaie d'aider
comme on peut et on s'entraide et puis
voilà et puis voilà quoi le regard des
autres c'était difficile à supporter
mais au fur et à mesure on a appris on a
appris à faire avec et maintenant on se
dit que nous on a de la chance on a
beaucoup de chance d'avoir Nicolas et
que voilà c'est notre c'est notre petit
ange et on est on est heureux qu'il soit
avec nous dans notre famille et ça se
passe bien
il s'adapte très facilement et au fil du
temps je veux dire les gens l'apprécient
énormément et
il y a aucun souci roman Nicolas c'est
maman c'est pour te dire que ben écoute
je suis vraiment heureuse et d'être ta
maman et j'espère que tu es content
d'être dans notre famille et on t'aime
fort fort et tu es une petite boule
d'amour et on t'aime Nicolas donc c'est
ton c'est ton papa écoute nous on t'aime
beaucoup on t'apprécie et on va tout
faire pour que tu avances dans la vie et
on va essayer de t'encadrer au maximum
et il y a ton grand frère qui pense
souvent à toi comme toi tu penses
souvent lui
Nicolas nous invite ensuite à découvrir
sa chambre son univers
non
puis c'est au tour des grands-parents de
Nicolas de nous en dire un peu plus sur
leur petit-fils Nicolas lui de par son
handicap il a besoin quand même qu'on le
qu'on le prenne
qu'on le soutient qu'on le garde donc il
est souvent avec nous ce qui fait que la
maison n'est pas vide la maison
authentique toujours des cris de Nicolas
de voilà c'est il y a de la vie dans la
maison
Nicolas a l'habitude lorsqu'il arrive de
l'IME le soir de me téléphoner Nicolas
monte en fait on habite à 2 km plus haut
et Nicolas veut à tout prix monter à la
maison parce que il y a des outils il
aime jouer avec les outils il vient
travailler et là il prend les outils il
prend mon ordinateur il prend la
tablette et il s'amuse il fait ce qu'il
est capable de faire avec et ça m'étonne
souvent de voir que Nicolas est capable
de mettre en marche un ordinateur avec
un mot de passe j'ai taper des lignes
assez complexes alors qu'on n'a pas
réussi jusqu'à présent à lui apprendre à
lire et à écrire apparemment il a des
capacités qui sont différentes des
nôtres
alors ce que j'aimerais faire c'est de
lancer un appel à ceux qui nous dirigent
à ceux qui ont le pouvoir de décision
quoi qu'il n'oublie pas tous ceux qui
sont différents
Nicolas était à l'IME au-delà de 18 ans
aurélieme s'est fait jusqu'à 18 ans on
le garde parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
solutions il manque cruellement de place
pour les personnes handicapées adultes
bien souvent c'est le retour à la maison
et le retour à la maison c'est vraiment
problématique pour les parents grâce à
oblige les parents en quelquefois à ne
plus travailler pour pouvoir rester avec
la personne
et ça il faut que nos élus tous ceux qui
nous regardent soient conscients de cela
Nicolas j'ai pas besoin de te le dire tu
sais très bien que ta mamie t'adore je
sais bien que tu es souvent avec Papi
comme papi l'indice et que tu es souvent
là où il est mais tu tiens une très
grande place dans mon cœur et ça je
crois que je le sais
c'est sur ces messages et cette émotion
d'une famille très unie que s'achève
notre émission la semaine prochaine nous
vous invitons à la cascade Niagara de
Sainte-Suzanne pour un pique-nique tous
ensemble une répétition en pleine nature
et quelques surprises à très bientôt